the senator from kentucky
i rise today to begin to filibuster john
brennan's nomination for the cia
i will speak until i can no longer speak
i will speak as long as it takes
until the alarm is sounded from coast to
coast
that our constitution is important that
your rights to trial by
jury are precious that no americans
should be killed
by a drone on american soil without
first being charged with a crime without
first
being found to be guilty by a court
holder's speech comes five months after
a u.s drone
killed the u.s born cleric anwar
al-awlaki in yemen
united states citizenship alone does not
make
does not make such individuals immune
from being
targeted the drone in yemen two weeks
later killed awlaki's
old son also a u.s citizen the obama
administration has steadfastly refused
to provide the specific legal case
behind the killing of the three
in keeping with white house policy
during his remarks holder refused to
even confirm the existence of the cia
joint special operations command drone
program that carried out the attack
this is the most transparent
administration in history
and yeah i can document how that is the
case
what will you do to create a legal
framework to make american citizens
within the united states
know that drone strikes cannot be used
against american citizens well
first of all i think
there's never been a drone used on an
american citizen on american soil
i'm not accusing anybody of being that
evil but what i
am saying is that in a democracy you
could someday elect someone
who is very evil that's why we don't
give the power
work to the government due process
and judicial process are not one and the
same
particularly when it comes to national
security
to give up on that principle to give up
on the bill of rights to give up on the
fifth amendment protection
that says that no person shall be held
without due process
that no person shall be held for a
capital offense
without being indicted tell the
president to do what i think really is
in his heart and that is to say
absolutely we're not going to be killing
americans not in a combat situation that
we will obey the constitution that the
fifth amendment does apply to all
americans
and there aren't exceptions but i thank
you very much for the
forbearance and i yield the floor